Of course,
you know that nature was the philosopher
who announced the death of God,
right,
and who is a great,
great critic of Christianity at vicious
critic of Institutional Christianity in
the best sense,
you know,
and he announced the death of God and he
said that we'd never find enough water
to wash away the blood.
It wasn't a triumphant proclamation even
though it's often read that way and
niches conclusion from that,
from the death of God,
the fact that our ethical systems,
we're going to collapse.
When the foundation was pulled out from
underneath him,
he believed that human beings would have
to find their own values to create their
own values,
and there's a problem with that because
it doesn't seem.
This is something Carl young was very
thorough in investigating,
doesn't really look like people are
capable of creating their own values
because you're not really capable of
molding yourself just any old way.
You want to be like you have a nature
that you have to contend with,
and so it isn't a matter of creating our
own values because we don't have that
capacity.
It might be a matter of rediscovering
those values,
which is what [inaudible] was attempting
to do now.
And,
and,
and so I think Nietzsche was actually
profoundly wrong in that,
in that recommendation.
I think he was psychologically wrong.
Now,
you know,
there was [inaudible] wrote in many ways
in parallel to.
Nisha was a great influence on Ninja.
Their,
their lives parallel each other to a
degree that's somewhat miraculous and in
some senses it's quite uncanny.
Dostoevsky was obviously a literary
figure,
whether whereas nature was a
philosopher,
a literary philosopher,
but still a philosopher and Dostoevsky
wrestled with exactly the same problems
that,
that nature wrestled with and,
but he did it in a different way.
He didn't literary manner and he has
this great book and the brothers
Karamazov.
And in that book there's a hero of the
book is really Leo Show Who's a monastic
novitiate,
a very good guy,
kind of a,
not an intellect,
but,
uh,
a person of great character,
you know,
and,
but he has a brother Ivan,
who's his older brother who a great
intellect and,
and a very handsome soldier and a brave
man.
And like Dostoyevsky's villains,
Ivan isn't exactly a villain,
but that's close enough.
Ivan or Dostoevsky makes his villains
extraordinarily powerful.
So if Dostoevsky's trying to work out an
argument,
he,
he clothes the argument in the,
in the flesh of one of his characters,
and if it's an argument he doesn't agree
with and he makes that character as
strong as he possibly can,
as strong and as attractive and
intelligent as he possibly can.
And then he let him just have outer.
And so Ivan is constantly attacking Lee
Osha and from every direction trying to
knock him off his perch of faith,
let's say,
and the Osha Lee.
Osha can't address a single one of
Ivan's criticisms and,
and he doesn't have the intellect for
it.
And,
and,
and Ivan has a devastating intellect.
It's devastating to him himself as well.
What happens in the brothers Karamazov
essentially is the daily.
Alicia continues to act out his
commitment to the good,
let's say.
And in that manner,
he's triumphant.
It doesn't matter that he loses the
arguments because the arguments aren't
exactly the point.
The arguments in some sense are aside.